digamos que fx es igual al valor
absoluto de x menos 3 sobre x menos 3
pero en realidad no nos importa tanto
ahorita esto sino lo que nos va a
importar va a ser el límite de fx cuando
x se aproxima a 3 inspeccionando la
función podrás darte cuenta que para
cuando x es igual a 3 no está definida
la función pues tendríamos un 0 sobre 0
y esto no está definido así que digamos
que efe de x va a ser igual lo vamos a
escribir por acá f x va a estar definida
como la siguiente forma pero vamos a
tener como dos casos en esta ocasión
porque vamos a tomar en cuenta primero
para todas aquellas x que son lo voy a
escribir de otro color para todas
aquellas x mayores que 3 y también nos
vamos a fijar para las x menores que 3 y
en este primer caso para cuando las x
son mayores que 3 podemos ver que
siempre vamos a tener en esta parte un
valor positivo aparte del valor absoluto
pues será mayor la x
y en la parte de abajo también
tendríamos un valor positivo entonces lo
podemos simplificar
de esta forma dejándolo así pues como te
decía aquí al restarle el 3 a las equis
no afecta mucho y más aparte pues
tenemos lo que es el valor absoluto y
siempre es positivo y entonces ahora sí
podemos simplificar también nuestra
función de esta forma porque aquí
tenemos un 1 entonces esto es para
cuando las x son mayores que 3 ahora hay
que pensar muy bien en qué pasará cuando
nosotros tomemos valores para x menores
que 3 pues si te puedes dar cuenta aquí
arriba tendríamos algo negativo pero con
el valor absoluto pues esto no afecta
pero sin embargo en la parte del
denominador nos sigue quedando dicho
signo negativo entonces esto de aquí se
vería reflejado de esta forma entonces
podemos hacer lo mismo que arriba esto
sería igual a 11 pero sin olvidar el
signo negativo que nos queda entonces en
este caso es menos 1 para las x menores
que 3 y si crees que esto no te está
sonando muy lógico para tratar de
entenderlo mejor hay que
dando valores a las x como por ejemplo
3.1 3.001 o bien 67 cualquier número que
resulte mayor a 3 y verás que obtienes
el 1 y luego bien tratas con valores
menores a 3 cualquiera que te guste y ve
podemos ver que también esto te va a
arrojar el menos 1 y para verlo
gráficamente aquí vamos a trazar nuestro
eje de las x y por acá nuestro eje del
ayer que es igual a fx y luego entonces
vemos que nuestro límite es cuando se
aproxima a 3 entonces tenemos 123 por
acá y los demás números no nos interesa
por este lado tenemos en el eje del
acceso efe x el 1 y el menos uno por acá
y luego entonces vamos a trazar lo que
nos dice aquí tenemos que esta función
se refleja que es igual para las x
mayores que 3 esto es igual a 1 pero
recordemos que está indefinido o no
tenemos aquí nada
cuando x es igual a 3 pues este valor no
se vale para nuestra función y ahora
para cuando tomamos x menores que 3 ésta
es la constante también de la función
menos 1 y de igual forma que cuando
teníamos la del 1 lo tratamos por acá e
igual en el 3 indefinido y nuestra
gráfica de la función luce así ahora
algo importante tratemos de responder
una pregunta cuál es el límite de fx
cuando x se aproxima a 3 y pensemos en
el límite para cuando nos acercamos en
la dirección negativa entonces
tendríamos lo siguiente déjame lo noto
por acá el límite de fx cuando x
aproxima a 3 por la parte negativa y
tenemos por aquí que alrededor de 3
tomando valores que se aproximen y que
sean menores que 3 entonces esto sería
por el lado izquierdo de esta forma
ahora bien tomando valores muy cercanos
por ejemplo empecemos con el 0 el 0 al
sustituir una función nos va a dar que
va
igual a 1 a menos uno perdón y luego si
tomamos el 2 nos va a dar menos 1 si
tomamos el 2.99 999 vemos que tiende a
aproximarse también también menos 1
entonces el límite se aproxima al menos
1 cuando estamos hablando del lado
izquierdo ahora tomando la aproximación
del límite de nuestra función fx
pero cuando x se aproxima 3 por la
derecha igual vamos a ir tomando valores
que estén más cercanos a 3 y sean
mayores que éste no sé el 5 luego el 4 y
en fin vemos que todos estos se
aproximan a un límite que será igual a 1
y si puedes tú ver tenemos algo extraño
porque vimos que acercándonos del lado
negativo o por la izquierda este se
aproxima menos 1 y que por el otro lado
es 1 entonces cuando nos aproximamos a
dos diferentes valores vemos que el
límite no existe
no existe o diciéndolo de otra forma me
gustaría escribirlo por acá abajo para
dejar la idea clara y lo voy a escribir
de otro color mejor para que se vea
explícito entonces vemos que el límite
de f de x cuando x aproxima a c es igual
a l
si y sólo si sí y sólo así cuando
tenemos el límite de fx cuando x se
aproxima a algún valor por la izquierda
es igual al límite de fx cuando x se
aproxima a ciertos valores pero por la
derecha y cuando esto pasa estos son
iguales a l y entonces se respeta lo que
estamos diciendo y tenemos un límite y
como vemos aquí no se está respetando
entonces este límite una vez más lo
repito no existe en conclusión si los
límites de ambas direcciones no
coinciden entonces no existe